[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down how Bubba Fett
survived the events of Return of the
Jedi the last time we saw the galaxy's
most famous bounty hunter he was on his
way to a thousand years of painful
digestion but we now know that he's
gonna be coming back in a big bad way
throughout this video we're gonna be
discussing how the character managed to
survive his fate and what he did after
it we'll also be giving our theories on
how he could be brought back into the
show and whether he's going to be a hero
or a villain there will be some spoilers
here so if he don't want anything
potentially ruined about the series then
I highly recommend that he turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
how Boba Fett's survived okay so the
Hollywood report had dropped the news on
Friday that bobba fett would be
appearing in the Mandalorian and that he
would be played by none other than
Tamera Morrison this was the actor that
played Jango Fett in attack of the
clones and it's great to see him back
that was used as a template for the
clone troopers and he was also given an
unaltered clone for his son which he
named Baba so it makes sense that he's
reprising his role as the bounty hunter
now though I have seen some unsure on
whether he would be appearing in
flashback and if the Sarlacc would
indeed still remain as his death due to
Morrison's age in the fact that the show
has already set five years after the
events of Return of the Jedi it does
make sense to have the character older
let's face it we all want to know what
happened to him and in the wake of the
cancelled Boba Fett's solo movie there's
never been a better time to truly
explore what happened on Tatooine but
how exactly did he get to this point and
have we seen him before well in episode
5 of the Mandalorian we did get a tease
that a mysterious figure would be
appearing in the show in the episode
mano teamed up with the rookie bounty
hunter in an attempt to hunt down Panik
shant things kind of went awry but the
episode ended with a mysterious pair of
boots and cape approaching Chan's body
this was confirmed by the creative team
to be Mothe Gideon however I do think
that in light of the recent announcement
that this will retro actively be changed
to Fett bother is of course
a bounty hunter so his tracking of Shann
makes sense and it could also set up how
he will appear in the show which I'll
get into in just a bit
now as for how he survived in every
version of the characters resurrection
he came out the same way however for
this breakdown we'll be focusing on
above like that
the tale of Boba Fett by JD Montgomery
the book was published in 1996 and had
pretty much centered around how Fett
managed to escape the Sarlacc
now in the book upon landing in the pit
Fett awaken the consciousness within it
one of its first victims was a young
join on a sous a Joe and his mind had
been melded with the pit and it was as
much him as he was it sous a Joe had
pretty much become the pit and over
millennia it had existed by injecting
its prey with neurotoxins and then it
slowly digested them with its stomach
acids Fett was able to communicate with
Zeus a Joe telepathically and during
this time he learned that they were one
in the same thus if he was able to fool
through say Joe he would be able to
escape that tricked the creature into
wrapping itself around his jet pack
which then exploded hurtling him free of
the monsters tentacles using a
concussion grenade he was able to escape
through a wall in the creature and he
finally made it to safety now what
happens from here kind of varies
depending on what you read in Star Wars
legends he's actually found by a sand
crawler that just so happened to have
also kidnapped r2d2 han Solo and Leia on
a rescue mission for the Droid and it's
here that they cross paths with Bette
solo didn't want to harm the Bounty
Hunter but he attacked the character and
hand managed to dive off the sand
crawler just as it hurtled back into the
pit so yeah this is the kind of fan
fiction we used to get he got out of the
pit and then he went immediately back in
however Fett managed to escape once more
in the same manner as before and he was
found by dengar who had come to search
through the wreckage of Jabba's bodge
then God didn't know that this was Fett
due to the damage on his armor and he
helped to get him back on his feet and
took him away to be healed they kind of
had a back-and-forth rivalry over the
heirs but one of the notable things that
happened to Fett was that he actually
returned to the pit one year after
escaping it he was originally going to
destroy it but using his telepathic
connection with the creature he decided
not to I think that this story will
pretty much be carried over
the show except for the whole in-and-out
storyline involving Han Solo cuz it
makes fat look a bit stupid which which
he definitely doesn't need more of he
has to escape in some way so they might
as well keep it as simple as possible
and yeah it does seem a bit like bad
fanfiction to have him climb out and
then almost immediately go back in now
the way I think that he will be brought
back into the show is through a similar
thing that we've already seen I do
believe that he will be revealed as
tracking down SH and and with the bounty
still on baby on his head I think he
will be the one to go after the
character first Mothe Gideon has already
failed and it's likely that the price
for the little youngling has now
increased greatly becoming an even more
valuable target for bounty hunters
we know that Fett has worked with the
Empire before and that he was
instrumental in tracking down Han Solo
perhaps Gideon knows of his exploits and
has gone after him personally in order
to give him a job that he really can't
refuse now there are two ways that that
can really go and that is either as a
friend or a foe and kind of using common
sense here to predict the way that I
think the show will venture though I may
be completely wrong however I think that
that will initially start off as a
villain and now his appearance is said
to be small who doesn't want to see
mando and fat facing up against one
another it's potentially one of the
biggest battles that there could be in
Star Wars and it would just bring so
much hype to the show that even non
subscribers of Disney Plus would likely
sign up just to see it go down I think
that might actually be mono - either in
a space battle or from afar however upon
getting in close and seeing that a
Mandalorian is guarding his target he
might have a change of heart
again that that's not really the fact we
know who tends to be a bounty hunter or
for everything but I'm just saying how I
think the show will operate they'll Fett
isn't technically a Mandalorian himself
I think you will find some common ground
within Joran and this may be the main
thrust of the episode that he features
in din was of course saved by the
Mandalorians himself and then brought in
to the creed and both in some ways
mirror one another they are both
characters that took up the lifestyle of
the Mandalorians and pretty much plays
into every aspect of who they are and
what they
I think that due to fetes reputation
that didn't we'll look up to the
character and after the pair-bond fair
may even become a mentor that could give
him some advice the other part is said
to be small a thing that there is
potential here for him to be a returning
character as it just doesn't make sense
to resurrect Fett and then kill him off
at the first available opportunity that
is unless of course Disney want to show
that they actually real Star Wars now
and there's no way that any of their
characters would be beaten by the older
ones they're kind of playing with fans
emotions right now and hearing the
characters return did bring a lot of
positivity towards the Disney Plus show
so I think it would be stupid to take
all of this goodwill and scrap it at the
first available opportunity the
Mandalorian season two is currently
playing heavily into fanservice
and we've seen a lot of announcements
surrounding this recently firstly ahsoka
was / out there and within the last
couple of days it's also been announced
that Bogut an is back as well I think
it's a smart move on Disney's part now
that all of the new characters are
established to bring in the elder ones
it would be amazing if baby Oda was
trained by ahsoka and manda was mentored
by Fett these are the kinds of scenes
that fans want to play out in their
shows and it would be a dream come true
for many Star Wars heads let's face it
Disney dropped the ball with their
handling of the Star Wars sequels and I
think memorable moments like this would
fully restore the fate that fans lost in
the studio or what could happen is that
it just pops back up in the cantina and
looks over and give give us a little nod
just a little nod and then he's off
again
- to who knows where and then Palpatine
shows up for some reason and it turns
out that he was controlling a hall from
behind the shadows now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on how the
character is coming back and whether you
think he's gonna be a hero or a villain
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out a
breakdown of all the west-world season 4
fan theories we go through what we think
will happen in the show so it's
definitely worth checking out after this
if you want to support the channel from
in Zulueta it's 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
massively appreciate it and it's a thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat to us after the show
either follow us at Definition YT or
click the
SCOR link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
are subscribe to the channel and this
Monty can win the marble face repot one
box then all you have to do is comment
on a video and make sure you sit with no
applications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of May and the cell be shipped
out from then to ever get surprised it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best now see you next time take
care peace
[Music]